la démission du président nixon n'est
plus qu'une question de quelques heures
semble-t-il elle a demandé au réseau
radio télévisée de l'ensemble des
chaînes couvrant le territoire des
etats-unis de lui réserver une heure
d'antenne pour ce soir 9 heures heure de
new york
c'est à dire 2 heures du matin heure
française ne manquez pas d'écouter à
partir de 2h du matin france inter pour
connaître les derniers développements de
la situation qui a amené monsieur nixon
au bord du gouffre et qui est la
conséquence directe d'un solution soir
de l'affairé watergate
la décision de nixon paraît avoir été
prise hier après un entretien qu'il a eu
avec monsieur barry goldwater un
sénateur forte influent ancien candidat
lui même et la présidence de la
république des états unis monsieur
gaubert aurait dit à monsieur nixon que
si celui ci était traduit devant le
sénat des états unis transformée pour la
circonstance en cour de justice il n'y
trouverait pas plus de 15 sénateurs qui
lui demeurer favorables
or il lui faut un minimum de 34 voix
pour échapper à la destitution à cette
quasi certitude d'une destitution
humiliante le président nixon paraît
donc avoir préféré la démission
volontaire en deux siècles d'existence
les états unis d'amérique n'ont jamais
connu une telle situation tant que
monsieur nixon n'a pas parlé nous ne
pouvons nous exprimer bien entendu qu'au
conditionnel une atmosphère de tension
extrême règne en tout cas à l'intérieur
de la maison blanche
mais le président le vice président ford
a été convoqué par le président nixon
entretien d'une heure dix la fp câble
est à 17h45
on rapporte de sources privées à la
maison blanche que le président nixon a
formellement informé monsieur ford de sa
décision de démission
constitutionnellement un président des
états unis doit remettre sa démission au
secrétaire d'état au ministre des
affaires étrangères en l'occurrence mais
ce qui suggère or celui ci était appelée
à la maison blanche cet après midi pour
la troisième fois en 24 heures voici les
éléments dont je dispose par dépêche
je vais appeler à washington bernard
valette pour qu'il nous en dise
davantage avoue washington
ça fait maintenant appel à caractère
pour comprendre la décision du président
nixon il faut remonter au samedi 27
juillet ce jour là la commission
judiciaire de la chambre des
représentants procèdent au vote du
premier chef d'inculpation retenus
contre le président nixon celui d'
obstruction à la justice
après trois mois de réunions à huis clos
consacrée à l'examen des témoignages la
commission vote devant les caméras de la
télévision
150 millions d'américains attendent des
38 membres de la commission de savoir si
leur président va être inculpé
et s'ils vont réclamer la procédure de
destitution par 27 voix pour contre 11
le premier chef d'inculpation est retenu
le lendemain
la même commission retiendra celui
d'abus de pouvoir le président nixon qui
a réuni son cabinet à la maison blanche
c'est maintenant que son procès va
s'ouvrir le 16 août trois jours plus tôt
la cour suprême l'instance devant
laquelle même le président des états
unis doit s'incliner rejette le
privilège de l'exécutif et somme le
président des états unis de remettre à
la justice les 64 bande magnétique qu'il
possède nixon dont la popularité n'est
plus aux états unis que de 24% s'incline
il sait que le contenu de ces bandes va
lui être fatale aussi le 5 août
demande-t-il au porte parole de la
maison blanche monsieur warren de
convoquer la presse lui même s'embarque
avec toute sa famille sur son yacht pour
une courte croisière sur le potomac
les bruits les plus divers circulent à
washington
on parle de démission de la mise à
l'écart du président qui invoquerait
l'article 25 de la constitution
on ne s'attendait sûrement pas à la
déclaration en 500 mots que monsieur
warren distribuer le président nixon
reconnaissait qu'il avait été mis au
courant du cambriolage du watergate
cinq jours seulement après qu'il se soit
produit reconnaissait également qu'il
avait fait pression sur le fbi est sur
la cia reconnaissait enfin qu'il avait
trompé la justice et ses avocats cet
aveu de mensonges soulève un tollé
général et la réprobation républicains
et démocrates réclament le départ du
président nixon et font savoir que de
toute manière ils voteront la
destitution ses plus fidèles supporteurs
qu'il s'agisse des sénateurs griffin
leader de la minorité républicaine au
sénat où wiggins chef de la même
minorité à la chambre des représentants
presse le président d'éviter un procès
infamant leur ton est dramatique mais le
président réunit à nouveau son cabinet
et sa réponse et je ne démissionnerai
pas remis il semble donc que l'on
s'oriente de plus en plus vers le procès
en destitution
mais le président nixon est pressé par
son entourage
il se rend compte qu'il est seul à un
moment critique tout le monde quitte ou
à quitter le navire
hier sa famille son cabinet le vice
président les leaders du congrès se
retrouvaient autour de lui est unanime
ils lui ont conseillé une nouvelle fois
de démissionner aujourd'hui
la pression s'est faite plus forte et le
président nixon transmettait ces
dossiers le fait de donner sa démission
lui se raconte et sûrement et l'on doute
qu'ils soient poursuivis en tant que
simple citoyen c'est à dire monsieur
nixon mais dans la carrière de richard
nixon
les rebondissements les coups de théâtre
les volte-face sont nombreuses et
imprévisible del annonce officielle de
la démission du président nixon 24
heures sur la lune programmera aussi
bien dans ses journaux de 13 heures que
de 19h45 demain des émissions spéciales
que nous avons préparée et qui vous
retraceront et la carrière du président
nixon et sa vie ainsi que le portrait de
son successeur
monsieur gérald fort demain bien entendu
nos programmes subiront de nombreux
changements si la démission de monsieur
nixon se produisait effectivement dès
12h30 un premier document le discours
qu'il doit prononcer julie sait tenir
deux heures à 13 heures une émission
spéciale qui se prolongerait jusqu'au
vers 14 heures le soir notre édition
normale du journal télévisé de 19h45 à
20h15 à dire la présente édition
comprendrait à son sommaire tous les
témoignages
toutes les déclarations importantes
concernant l'événement lui-même ensuite
à 20h30 c'est à dire après le feuilleton
un grand programme spécial préparé et
présenté par toute l'équipe de 24 heures
soit une en conséquence plein cadre
serait reportée à une date ultérieure et
naturellement devant l'importance
exceptionnelle qu'aurait la démission
confirmé du président des états unis
nous enverrons prions le programme tout
au cours de la journée s'il y avait eu
lieu de le faire par des flashes
spéciaux je pense qu'au cours de la
présente édition ferait encore quelque
chose à vous dire à propos du président
nixon voyons d'autres sports
tellement ils se sont rencontrés mais
avec une heure de retard il c'est à dire
les ministres des affaires étrangères de
la grèce du royaume uni et de la turquie
les trois pays garants de l'indépendance
cypriote les entretiens privés ont été
nombreux et difficiles cet après midi à
genève avant que messieurs callaghan
mavros et gunesh puisse installer dans
la salle du conseil au palais des
nations de genève pour entamer la
deuxième phase des négociations sur
l'avenir de chypre
il s'agit de la seconde phase la
première s'était terminée le 30 juillet
sur un cessez-le-feu qui n'est en fait
jamais rentré en vigueur ce qui explique
la rigueur et la mauvaise humeur cet
après-midi de monsieur mavros lorsqu'il
est arrivé à genève
il craint qu'il ne puisse discuter avec
un ministre affaires étrangères turc
dont il craint qu'il ne reste que
respecte pas ses engagements alors dans
un premier temps va donc essayer de
cette fois ci de se mettre d'accord sur
un cessez-le-feu qui puisse être
respecté
ensuite grecs turcs et britanniques mais
cette fois rejoint par le président
chypriote monsieur clerides assez le
vice président monsieur denktash vont
envisager le statut futur de l'île
en effet la constitution de 1960 n'a
jamais été complètement respecté les
turcs souhaiterais que l'on puisse
établir une fédération avec deux
communautés turque et grecque autonome
une fédération dont les grecs ne veulent
pas la négociation de genève qui a
commencé ce soir va donc sans doute être
longue et difficile
paris les halles monsieur chirac après
une réunion avec mais ce galet et jaro
pour étudier les problèmes de la qualité
de la vie a fait une visite impromptue
sur le chantier des halles
il n'a fait aucune déclaration à ce
sujet mais on pense que des décisions
financières intéressant l'aménagement
des halles pourrait être prise
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle qu
avant-hier mardi à l'elysée à l'occasion
d'une réunion de travail consacrée à
l'aménagement du quartier des halles
monsieur giscard d'estaing président de
la république avec un être son intention
de remplacer le centre international de
commerce prévue sur l'emplacement des
anciennes halles de paris par un espace
vert rarement un quartier de la capitale
aura suscité autant de polémiques
à quand remonte le début des discussions
quelles sont les conséquences de la
décision du président
la république voici pour que vous
puissiez juger le lot si les halles
c'est une histoire à rebondissements à
l'origine une décision imposée pour des
raisons essentiellement techniques le
transfert des halles du centre de la
capitale
a rungis paris qui n'a plus de ventre va
retrouver un coeur car au delà de la
polémique de caractère esthétique et
fonctionnel qui entoure la décision de
détruire les pavillons baltard la fête
envahi ces lieux désertés il manquait à
paris un lieu de rencontre des changes
les parisiens semblaient l'avoir trouvé
mais voilà cet emplacement devait
susciter un grand nombre de projets plus
ou moins désintéressés
le conseil de paris tranche et donne son
feu vert à une vaste opération de
rénovation de zone principale à l'est
sur le plateau beaubourg création d'un
centre d'art contemporain
déjà surnommé george pompidou il s'agit
de mettre sur cet espace de deux
hectares une grande bibliothèque
publique d'information à département des
arts plastiques qui regroupera le musée
national d'art moderne le sens national
d'art contemporain une documentation
spécialisée il s'agit également de
mettre le centre de création
industrielle et de faire intervenir la
recherche musicale et acoustique dans un
institut de recherche et coordination
acoustique musique qui se trouve
enterrée à côté du centre beaubourg au
chevet de l'église san et un bâtiment
qui fait qu'ils couvrent 10 mille mètres
carrés au sol qui a cinq étages et qui
se trouve au milieu d'un environnement
de deux hectares où l'on trouve des
endroits piétonnier des lieux de
promenade et de détente que ce soit la
place qui se trouve devant le centre
cela place qui se trouve au chevet de
l'église st mary où la place d'areni qui
se trouve un peu en dehors du périmètre
vaut un peu plus à l'ouest
un grand forum souterrain hauteur et aux
alentours du rer en construction enfin à
l'emplacement des anciennes halles à
proximité de la bourse du commerce de
l'église saint-eustache
un centre de commerce international 94
mille mètres carrés dont quatorze mille
en surface un centre d'affaires et
d'information pour 4 à 500 sociétés
françaises et étrangères qui pourraient
disposer de locaux
mais ce centre de commerce international
on le sait depuis mardi ne verra pas le
jour
le président de la république a été
catégorique le projet doit être
abandonnée au profit des espaces verts
il faut le dire ce centre avait suscité
bien des critiques de la part
d'associations pour la protection du
site et récemment encore son permis de
construire avait été annulé par le
tribunal administratif de pas
apparemment personnes s'attendaient à
cette décision
quand je suis d'autant plus déçu que
vous mmes interviewé à peu de choses
près à l'endroit où président de la
république ministre des finances il ya
un an au mois de juillet déclaré sur cet
emplacement qu'il était venu
salué l'assemblée des centres
internationaux dans le monde 40 nations
dont les ruches des américains et c'est
un écueil se réjouissait le jeune textes
l'un on se réjouissait d'être ici et du
choix du bâtiment dans les proportions
étaient compatibles avec le quartier et
qu'il souhaitait que paris capitale d'un
pays qui est 4e commerçants du monde et
possède un centre de formation
international alors c'est la 3d très
grande surprise la grande surprise alors
en fin de compte que va devenir cet
emplacement l'emmenant à ça je n'en sais
rien c'est que le seul que je sais ça
c'est je suppose que vous interview vrai
monsieur aaron le promoteur lui il a un
problème alors strictement financier
c'est à dire des sommes investies pour
en arriver à la situation nous trouvons
c'est-à-dire un trou de 20 mètres de
profondeur sur un hectare et demi ce qui
représente des centaines de milliers de
mètres cubes de terre des ingénieurs des
architectes des travaux de terrassement
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'argent mon
sens le fait de voir huit ans de travail
acharné d'une équipe qui croyant quelque
chose stoppez d'une seconde à l'autre ne
peut conclure que sur le sentiment
alors est ce que cela signifie que le
principe d'un grand centre d'affaires de
ce genre à paris est également enterré
pour le moment aucune information
précise à ce sujet pourtant on reconnaît
qu'un centre commercial international à
paris serait une chose importante
alors est ce que malgré tout le principe
risque d'être abandonnée définitivement
donc à présent il est ici en tout cas
savoir s'il sera proposé ailleurs et de
notre problème pour nous il n'est pas le
moment d'y penser
la seul axe d'action qui peut être le
nôtre d'abord et de sauvegarder le
terrain tels qu'ils existent faire en
sorte que les bâtiments avoisinants ne
ris pas le comme on dit vulgairement de
tomber dans le trop et puis ensuite nous
verrons
et pour le moment je crois que nos
préoccupations ne sont pas celles d'une
nouvelle conception risques éventuels
mentions vous appelle à vous pour
réaliser ce centre commercial
international peut-être dans un autre
endroit paris ou à la périphérie est ce
que vous répondriez présent il est
évident que notre goût a été d'étudier
ce genre de bâtiment que nous
comme étant très utile à l'économie d'un
pays puisqu'ils ont construit des
quantités dans le monde maintenant il
est non moins évident que compte de
cette expérience nous serions des
heureux de penser un nouveau bâtiment
faut-il encore savoir où il peut se
trouver
et puis surtout quelle sécurité nous
sera offerte cette fois ci pour que l'
ouvrage peut mener à bien
jusqu'au bout à l'hôtel de ville on
affiche une certaine déception
le conseil municipal n'a pas été
consulté pour cette nouvelle option
j'avoue avoir un petit regret c'est que
le conseil de paris et ses élus n'est
pas du tout était en conversation au
sujet de cette modification sur venu
pour l'aménagement des halles mais il
s'agit maintenant de savoir comment nous
pouvons le mieux faire cette opération
venant après les décisions concernant la
voie express rive gauche la cité fleurie
cette affaire d'aménagement aux deux
questions quel doit être le partage des
compétences entre le chef de l'état et
le conseil de paris et enfin s'agit-il
d'une action isolée ou d'une véritable
redéfinition de l'urbanisme parisien
les radicaux se sont souvent reconnus
dans les classes moyennes c'est
précisément le dossier les difficultés
des petites et moyennes entreprises que
robert fabre se proposait d'ouvrir
devant le premier ministre parmi les
mesures préconisées un desserrement du
crédit
le report de la majoration sur les
bénéfices offre d'abord prévue pour
aujourd'hui l'audience de la délégation
des radicaux de gauche à matignon devait
être reporté en septembre en raison d'un
calendrier chargé
fut-il précisé pour andré fabre il
s'agit là d'un bien mauvais départ quant
aux dialogues majorité opposition
monsieur giscard d'estaing avait semblé
vouloir ouvrir ce dialogue
tous ces propos consistait à dire qu'ils
étaient prêts à recevoir au niveau du
gouvernement les membres de l'opposition
nous constatons aujourd'hui que monsieur
chirac semble en désaccord avec
l'attitude et les propos de monsieur
giscard d'estaing alors qui a tort qui a
raison pourquoi qui censurent le carnet
de rendez vous du premier ministre sont
des questions qu'elle n'apporte pas de
réponse dans tous les cas nous le
regrettons car si le même état c store
comme auparavant que la france continue
à tokyo en deux au niveau du parlement
au niveau du pays bien c'est infiniment
regrettable
nous avions pris cette initiative nous
déplorons que n'ait pas eu de succès et
ce sera pas de notre faute si le
dialogue s'engage mal les groupes
communistes et socialistes de
l'assemblée nationale ont demandé la
convocation d'une session extraordinaire
du parlement afin de débattre de la
situation agricole en france
une délégation des deux groupes conduite
par monsieur robert ballanger et charles
josselin a indiqué à monsieur paul
maillot chargé de mission à la
présidence de l'assemblée le président
edgar faure est actuellement absent que
182 signature avait déjà été recueillies
monsieur ballanger a exprimé le souhait
que les députés de la majorité se
joignent à la gauche pour qu'on atteigne
le nombre requis de 243 députés afin de
pouvoir organiser une session spéciale
un débat devant l'opinion publique a
affirmé monsieur jocelyn pourrait éviter
une dégradation de la situation le parti
radical que préside monsieur
servan-schreiber insiste avec vigueur
dans un communi
ok pour que soit réexaminée la politique
de ventes d'armes de la france
le parti radical dit avoir appris sans
surprise des récentes informations
données par le président sadate d'égypte
et rappelle que depuis longtemps il
avait dénoncé les erreurs et les
équivoques des déclarations officielles
le parti radical s'associe aux
déclarations que vient de faire le
gouvernement
il ne s'agit que d'un avertissement vos
jours sont comptés
ainsi s'exprime l'organisation des
soldats de l'opposition algérienne qui
revendique l'attentât de la nuit
dernière contre l'office algérien du
tourisme
ce mouvement d'opposition au président
boumédiène avait déjà signé l'attentât
de marseille contre l'amicale les
algériens en europe mort de baldur von
schirach l'ancien chef des jeunesses
hitlériennes à l'âge de 68 ans n'était
sorti de la prison de spandau en 1966
von schirach avait organisé la jeunesse
hitlérienne avant l'arrivée d'hitler au
pouvoir en 1933
fait prisonnier à vienne en 1945 il
avait été condamné à 20 ans de prison
par le tribunal de nuremberg
24 heures sur la une a choisi ce soir de
vous donner une recette pour éviter que
vos jeunes enfants ne se perdent sur la
plage
tout d'abord garder l'oeil ouvert
l'accident n'arrive pas qu'aux enfants
des autres et pensez à mettre aux petits
qui ne peuvent encore s'exprimer
un bracelet en métal gravé ou un
sparadrap autour du poignet avec votre
nom et votre adresse de vacances votre
enfant pourra être ainsi très rapidement
retrouvé qu'est-ce qui ne va plus dans
le cyclisme professionnel
on s'est beaucoup posé la question sur
le plan purement sportif pendant le
dernier tour de france les coureurs
ayant été dans l'ensemble très décevant
vous connaissez la réponse merckx si
merck cela et cetera mais il se trouve
qu'on se repose la question aujourd'hui
mais c'est cette fois pour des raisons
extra sportives depuis quinze jours
en effet trois groupes publicitaires
importants ont décidé de ne plus
patronne et les coureurs qu'ils avaient
engagée et de se retirer des
compétitions cyclistes un groupe
français en selle depuis sept ans patron
d'anquetil deuil en scène ce et tout
récemment deux luys ocaña il laisse une
vingtaine de coureurs en chômage
un groupe espagnol chef de file manza
nec 32 coureurs à la recherche d'un
travail est un groupe italien
quinze coureurs sont aujourd'hui sans
emploi le cas français paraît exemplaire
et nous allons nous y attarder en 1967
donc le service publicité de cette
société décide de consacrer 20% de son
budget au patronage d'un groupe de
coureurs cyclistes 20% du budget cela
représente en gros 200 millions
d'anciens francs
il y à là de quoi former une équipe
solide avec un chef de file de renom
angt il avec jacques anquetil bien sûr
c'est le succès un succès inchiffrable
sur le plan financier
si bien que ce qui ne devait être qu'une
expérience de 1 an ou 2 va se poursuivre
lorsqu'en qu'il arrête le vélo on change
de vedettes et l'on prend janssens
lorsque y en scène s'arrête on prend
ocaña ocaña gagne le tour en 1973 alors
on continue
mais voilà qu'à la veille du tour 74
ocaña malade déclare forfait rupture de
contrat il n'y a plus de stars dans
l'équipe
les résultats sont décevants l'heure est
venue de stopper l'aventuré
si les résultats les mêmes j'avais
l'année dernière il est probable que
nous aurions il est même certain que
nous aurions continué n'a pas eu de
résultats cette année
dernièrement il en a fait part de la
sélection de l'étude française pour le
championnat du monde et un seul qui a
été retenue par le commandant mariés ce
qui prouve que nos coureurs ne sont plus
dans le coup pas de champions dans un
groupe pas de résultats pas de résultats
pas de bonne publicité
pas de bonne publicité pas d'argent le
processus est simple
il explique en partie la disparition des
trois groupes extra-sportifs déjà cités
les deux groupes de merckx et poulidor
pourrait également subir le même sort si
ses deux vedettes le quitter
ce n'est pas le niveau du sport cycliste
professionnel qui réparer les dégâts
cela étant il est une autre raison
beaucoup plus secrètes beaucoup plus
profonde est beaucoup plus grave de
l'extinction de ces groupes
c'est le prix des coureurs ces messieurs
les champions et les autres se font cher
et si l'on a la faiblesse d'exciter leur
convoitise
il ne peut plus être question de survie
on a pratiquement le meilleur coureur
français après coup leader il s'appelle
alain senti il a eu des offres du
concurrente française à nous à des prix
aussi absolument exagérés et je pense
que il réfléchira si on réfléchit pas
qu'ils voient que son intérêt et dans
l'immédiat et changements de maison je
fais rien pour le retenir
à ces prix là parce que de toute façon
je crois aucune surenchère dans la vie
ce fait il ya des bruits donné mais
qu'il faut surtout pas dépenser carences
des bons professionnels d'un côté
derrière merckx et poulidor il n'y a
personne surenchère excessive de l'autre
certaines maisons offre jusqu'à 50
millions par an grands noms du cyclisme
les groupes extra sportifs sont bien
loin d'avoir leur avenir devant eux
il sera intéressant en tout cas de voir
de quoi seront faites les courses de la
saison prochaine cheval c'est un
français thierry estèbe de la région de
colmar qui est en tête à rome aux
championnats d'europe de concours
complet d'équitation
juniors 1 celle sur purge l on a déjà
disputé le dressage le cross demain
dernière épreuve sur l'obstacle
espérons que thierry estève fera aussi
bien que l'adjudant chef du lion qui
remonte à la médaille d'or de cette
discipline aux jeux de mexico il ya six
ans
tiercé aujourd'hui outreau enghien dans
le prix de la victoire du numéro 9 bars
idées et en portant les couleurs de m
car c'est à dire celles qui furent
celles de gélinottes et qui était driver
par laure deuxième casdar u19 troisième
cristobal le 1
en somme 9 19 ans dimanche les rssi à
deauville on a choisi cet après-midi le
bris de la municipalité quatrième course
de la rhune
dans moins de trois semaines paris
célébrera le 30e anniversaire de sa
libération
en 44 le comité parisien de la
libération et le conseil de paris
annonce aujourd'hui dans un communiqué
que cette déclaration que cette
célébration se fera avec éclat une
plaque sera inauguré à l'emplacement de
l'ancienne gare montparnasse où les
représentants de
france sur la reddition du commandant
allemand de paris le général von
choltitz je vous rappelle que monsieur
nixon est au bord de la démission que
celle-ci par est infiniment probable
mais qu'elle ne s'est pas encore
produite
et puis il peut y avoir un coup de
théâtre il faut attendre ce que monsieur
nixon dire à cette nuit à 2 heures du
matin heure française
alors pour nos programmes de demain il
ya une subiront de nombreux changements
si la démission de monsieur nixon était
vive à 12h30 nous présenterions un
premier document c'est à dire le
discours qu'il doit prononcer à 2 heures
ce matin
ensuite un trésor notre journal télévisé
se transformerait en une édition
spéciale elle se prolongerait je pense
jusqu'aux environs de 14 heures le soir
le journal télévisé de 19h45 20h15
comprendre à son sommaire
tous les témoignages toutes les
déclarations concernant l'événement
lui-même
ensuite après le feuilleton sbires à
20h30
il y aura un grand programme spécial
préparé par toute l'équipe de 24 heures
en conséquence des missions plein cadre
que vous suivez toujours avec attention
serait reportée à une date ultérieure
pour marc rey que je parle au
conditionnel il ne nous semble pas c'est
en de parler de la démission de monsieur
nixon comme s'il était effective alors
que lui-même ne l'a pas encore annoncé
nous estimons qu'il faut t'attendre
naturellement devant l'importance
exceptionnelle qu'aurait la démission
effective du président des états unis
nous nous réservons le droit
d'interrompre le programme de demain
tout au long de la journée s'il y avait
lieu de le faire par des flashes
spéciaux
la tradition est terminé je pense vous
donner d'autres informations notamment
de washington lorsque nous nous
retrouvons si vous voulez bien
à 22h30 des poussières pour 24 heures
dernière bonne soirée
merci